>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
[ Silence ]
>> On behalf of the
audience thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> And my first question
to you Jason is
when exactly did you sell
your soul to the devil?
[ Laughter ]
Jason Robert Brown
>> The real question is
what did I get in exchange?
No, you know, I started, I started
playing, I begged my parents
for a piano when I was 7 I think.
And I have no musicians in
my family that's not sort
of part of the family tree.
We have no artists anywhere or at
least no actual artists anywhere.
And, but I said I wanted a piano and
my grandfather was sort of a hoarder
and he had them in his basement
and he had an old upright
in his basement which they
sort of brushed up a little bit
and one day I came into my
living room and there it was.
And so I sat down and started trying
to figure out how to play the thing
from Star Wars or something that
was kind of, that was that you know,
what I always say is, I was
the second child and as anyone
who is a second child or especially
anyone who is the first child knows,
you know, that means all I'm trying
to do all the time is get attention.
And so, you know, I was working
from a very early age to make sure
that people noticed me, so this
turned out to be the way to do it.
>> Did you start piano
lessons then or you?
Jason Robert Brown
>> I did, but only in the
most sort of rudimentary way,
because I wouldn't practice
because it wasn't gratifying.
[ Laughter ]
Uh-huh. And so I you know, I
took lessons for 3 or 4 years
but I never got to
any particular level.
I was sort of on you know the
John Brimhall book 3 and you know,
it was sort of you know, everyone
rolling their eyes every week.
But while I while I was doing
that I was also writing songs
and I would sit and write
songs and play in my own sort
of crazy idiosyncratic
way and do that.
So that I kind of then, my mother
was like well I'm not going
to keep paying for lessons if
you're never going to practice.
So I just kept playing
and playing and playing,
but I never was doing it
according to the books and I sort
of got self-taught as far as
theory and how to read charts
and chords and things like that.
And then right when I was about
to graduate from high school,
my mother said well what is
it you're planning to do?
I said, well I have to go to a music
school of course that's what I do.
And she said, well it would help
if you could read music probably,
that would, that might be
valuable and we sort of shoved me
into piano lessons for the last
year of high school and I sort
of crammed, how to figure out how
to integrate what I knew how to do
with what actually was on the page.
And I'm still not sensational
with the page
but I'm obviously a
lot better than I was.
>> I think there are a lot of sort
of aspiring musical theater
performers and writers here and ones
who are beyond aspiring, but I.
Jason Robert Brown
>> In both senses that way.
>> In both senses of the word.
I'm just fascinated about
how you guys work together.
I was able to watch a little
bit of your rehearsal before.
How do you evolve this
relationship and is there,
it's sort of like there's almost
a psychic connection there
of how you know reading each other
and how you're going
to work together.
Jason Robert Brown
>> I mean on my end,
really my belief is
that when you find the people
who connects to your material
and who you connect to musically,
the best thing you can do
is let them go do their job.
So, it's I don't sort of,
I don't think Shoshana
and I have ever had a rehearsal
where we sit and I sort
of micromanage the phrasing and sort
of say oh it should
be this and that.
Often what happens is
exactly what you saw today
where she's learned the song
from a recording that I send her
or something like that and then we
have like 20 minutes before the gig
and I'm like all right let's try it.
I might say one thing about oh,
no-no that's E flat not E natural
and she'll be like ahh, that'll
be the entirety of our rehearsal.
But, but it's, that's as much
as that's been the entirety
of our rehearsal, it's also one
of my favorite collaborations
in my life.
And whenever I can
sing with Shoshana I do
because she just gets the material.
And so I don't have to say oh
no the phrase should go this way
or what I meant for that, what
that's supposed to mean acting wise.
She gets it, she does it, she brings
herself to it and then I can get
out of the way, so
that's, that's my response.
You? Shoshana Bean
>> I think, well it took me a number
of years to get out of the way
and just let the, let
our connection be there
and let the music does it for you.
But I was so terrified of him and so
wanting to please him and so wanting
to do his incredible music justice
that I think it was just kind
of not stale but just a little
stiff and terrifying for me.
I don't know how it came across
but it was terrifying and then.
>> Jason Robert Brown
>> You were fine huh?
[ Laughter & Applause ]
Shoshana Bean
>> The gift for me
is, it's very rare
that you come across, thank you sir.
Psychic connection.
You see how that works?
That you as a singer or just an
artist in general with something
to say or feelings that you come
across someone who articulates them
so perfectly and also writes so
perfectly for your instrument.
And I think a lot of women
say that about Jason's work.
But me in particular, I feel like
myself in particular, It's just,
I think it's powerful connection to
his music and us together you know.
So for me it was just
getting out of the way
and just letting the connection
be there and not be afraid of it.
>> How do you set keys
and things like that
if you haven't rehearsed it?
Shoshana Bean
>> That's the magic of him.
He just knows, I've never gone to
him and been like this is too high
or this sits in a weird place.
There are very few male
composers who know exactly
where to put music for women.
And for me, I mean the songs aren't
even technically challenging.
I don't have to go through and
maneuver with my voice teacher
or anything like I do with
a lot of other composers
because they just fit
in my voice and a lot
of women's voices so easily.
Every once and awhile
there's a murderess vowel
or consonant on a murderess
note but.
Jason Robert Brown
>> Mine too.
Shoshana Bean
>> And they're not easy.
They're challenging but I
love, it's like, it's a one,
I feel like this is the moment I
get to feel like an Olympic athlete
as a singer when I'm
approaching Jason's material.
Jason Robert Brown
>> I mean part of that really
is, part of why Shoshana
and I can do the work we do together
is that part of her voice happens
to be just the part of the
voice that I work in the most
and that I like the most.
So, it's not like oh maybe I'll
take this down a half step,
because Shoshana's singing it
which I will do with other signers.
But Shoshana it's been pretty
much whatever key I throw
at her she's always like
oh that's good, that works.
Shoshana Bean
>> Are you serious?!
Jason Robert Brown
>> Oh yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Jason Robert Brown
>> No.
>> Do you do it from a recording, do
you provide the recording that she.
>> Jason Robert Brown
>> Well yeah, for the most
part, I mean you know,
we've now been doing these shows,
this has been more
than like 10 years.
It's probably been 12 years of
doing these things together,
so I don't even remember
how we first.
I think honestly when we first
did the gig you knew a lot
of the songs already that you just
sort of showed up and you were
like I know Still Hurting
and I know how
to do I'd Give It All
for You, oh okay.
Shoshana Bean
>> No, I think you gave me, now
I don't remember the original,
I mean some of them I
had done in college.
But now he just sends me, now
I'm known to ask for things.
>> Do you read music?
Shoshana Bean
>> I do, but I don't
need to with Jason.
With Jason it's a feeling
thing and if there's a question
of a specific note, I
mean I just, I ask him.
I don't look at the music.
Jason Robert Brown
>> No, I mean with, with Cassandra
which tonight she did
for the first time.
I mean that's the first time that
anyone's done that song here.
I sent her a recording of me
sort of, she had heard me do it.
We did a concert together in
London I guess, 2 months ago
and I sang Cassandra then and I
said, but when we do the concert
in D.C. you're singing
it and she was like okay.
And so, she had said you
better send it to me.
So I sent her a recording where
I was playing the piano part
and plunking out the
note at the same time
and then I sent her
just an accompaniment
that she could sing along to.
And so I sent that I and I
again, today was the first time
that we worked on it and you heard
you know, I started playing it,
she sang it and at the
end of it I said one thing
about one phrase and she said okay.
And she was like okay let's
do it again and that was it.
>> That was one of the
most fascinating things
when you were doing sort
of the run through is
as I recall you sang something
and then after you've gone
through the song you said,
remember that phrase.
She's not angry at him there,
she's genuinely wishing him well.
Shoshana Bean
>> Did I do, did I do it tonight?
Jason Robert Brown
>> I wasn't paying attention.
I was playing.
[ Laughter ]
Shoshana Bean
>> Mark, did I do it?
Did I do it?
>> Everything you do is perfect.
Shoshana Bean
>> I'm never leaving
the Library of Congress.
Isn't it great?
>> But it's fascinating
to me that the idea
of what an intension is
behind a song and a moment
versus what the singers bring
to it and I'm not even sure how
to articulate this question.
Jason Robert Brown
>> No, I think what
you're asking is this.
When you're a storyteller and I
think both of us are storytellers
as that's part of what we do.
It's much more effective for me
to tell you what the story is
that I need you tell than for me
to tell you how to tell that story.
If I had said to her, oh no do
it with this, go lighter on it
and you know, it should be
more piano and maybe sort
of hang this one note over by an
extra eighth note, that may be sort
of what I'm hoping comes out,
but it doesn't mean
she'll understand the story
that I want to tell.
All I have to say to her is no
that's supposed to be genuine
and it's supposed to
be sort of kind.
And by saying that I know
that she's going to interpret
that musically to mean something.
I don't know that with
every singer I work with
but I know that with Shoshana.
If I say something about what the
storytelling is supposed to be,
she knows how to tell stories with
the music as well as just sort
of say the words, but the music
is going to tell a story also
and I can, you know I can trust
that, I can say that and it works.
I hope.
Shoshana Bean
>> I'm flattered.
I nailed it tonight.
As you all can see, I nailed it.
[ Laughter ]
>> It interests me that most of what
you sang tonight are theater songs
and in a couple of cases you
sort of explicated the story,
especially with the new song.
But so often it seemed unnecessary
and yet there's a lot of detail
that may not be clear to the
audiences but somehow the meaning
and understanding comes through.
Shoshana Bean
>> That's because he's
a genius storyteller.
He's a genius and this is the
other thing I say to highlight
that fact is as singers
who learn music,
I don't know if you notice some
of the songs are 5 minutes long
and there's a lot of words.
And so whenever, like when
I got Cassandra I was like
and I called Eden, because my friend
Eden had just done it a couple
of weeks ago and I'm like did
you have to learn Cassandra?
She was like girl I did.
It's been a long time since I
had to learn a new song of his
and then I checked
myself and I was like,
the thing with Jason's
music is it's very wordy
and there are intricate changes
each time that make it difficult
to learn, but it also
tells such a clear story.
It's actually not difficult to
learn, because once you see the arch
of the story it tells itself
and your memory just
kind of hold on to it.
There are not a lot of
composers that do that.
Sometimes, even pop songs
today, I mean like the dumbest,
easiest pop songs, if they don't
tell a story they don't stick
in my mind, so that's, I mean
and also he's a great storyteller
which is why you don't
need to know the context.
You can just for your own.
Like King of the World, I'm
like what's that about and he's
like what do you want
it to be about?
[ Laughter ]
Jason Robert Brown
>> I, you know I used to
do a lot more explaining,
but I've been doing these concerts
for you know 25 years or something.
At this point I figure
people just go with it.
I used to just take
decades and decades
to explain what every
song was about.
I got so tired of the
sound of my voice
and I figured nobody's
here to hear me talk.
So I just moved on and
it seems to be all right.
Also, I suspected of
this audience, you know,
85% of them don't know everything
that I sang anyway
they don't need me
to tell the whole story
at this show.
>> Do you still enjoy
singing the songs over again?
Do you feel like okay I've got
to do this one now or it's?
Jason Robert Brown
>> No luckily, if I'm not
into it I don't do it anymore.
There's actually one song I
don't, I rarely let anybody do
and I would never do it on my own.
I haven't done.
I'm not afraid of anything.
I think in the last 5 years it
just got burned out on it so much.
It's a perfectly fine song I
just, I can't get behind it.
And if I can't get behind
it it's hard for me to play.
But we Stars and the Moon at
the rehearsal today and Stars
and the Moon you know, was I wrote
when I was 21 and it comes out
and I play it and it feels
great to play and so I'm sort
of like okay we can do that one.
I can always find something
in the music to connect me
to why wrote the song and
if I know why I wrote it
that usually helps me.
But I get burned out on things sure
but none of the stuff we did tonight
because if I'm burned out on it I
don't have to put it in the program.
>> Why didn't you do Stars and Moon?
Jason Robert Brown
>> We just ran out of time I mean.
We didn't do everything.
We didn't do Everywhere but Here,
we didn't do Stars and Moon.
>> No pressure.
Jason Robert Brown
>> We did songs.
Shoshana Bean
>> It was fun to run it today.
>> I think the most recent song
you wrote and performed was Hope.
Jason Robert Brown
>> Yes.
>> And I know, at least
as I understand it,
it was sort of a burst
of inspiration.
But do you remember why Hope
instead of fear or prayer
or I mean just the way you
came into that song it sort of,
there's something unexpected
about that word being the direction
you went with that feeling.
Jason Robert Brown
>> It actually it's the
serendipity of what happened.
I had been scheduled to perform,
Kristin Chenoweth was doing her show
on Broadway for about 2 weeks.
And one of the night, every night
she would have a special guest come.
And she had asked if I would
come and be a special guest
that she was doing 50 Years
Long actually in her set.
And she said, would you
come and be a special
and maybe sing something
new because the audience,
that would be kinky
for the audience.
And so on Election Day
itself it was sort of like,
hey I wonder what I'm going to sing
for Kristin's show, I have no idea.
And then you know, the end
of the world and then I.
[ Applause ]
If you're not one of us it's fine,
just know that's how we feel.
All right.
[ Applause ]
So I got up that morning and
I really thought I'm not going
to go sing with Kristin Chenoweth,
that's not how that's going to go.
But I thought well I can't
leave Kristin in the lurch,
what am I supposed to sing?
And I was like if I sing you know,
if I sing like the Old Red Hills
of Home or [inaudible] it's
just, it's deeply hostile.
There's just no way to and I
didn't want to be hostile, I didn't
and especially if Kristin's show
which is all you know, sparkly
and twirly and you
know all that stuff.
And so I thought what
am I supposed to say.
The first two lines of the song
while I was making breakfast in sort
of daze, because I don't think
any of us slept, I sort of,
I said I've come to
sing a song about hope.
And I don't mean it but that's
what I'm here to sing about.
And so as I said that I thought,
I guess maybe I'll write a song.
Maybe, I don't know what
time is it, can I, cause I,
I'm a very slow writer in general
but I thought I don't
know maybe I can do it.
And we had to go that morning
my daughter was interviewing,
she's going into 7th grade
and she was interviewing
for a very schwansy [assumed
spelling] private girls school
on the Upper East Side.
And so my wife and daughter went off
to go to the interview and I said,
I'll meet you in a minute I
just have to take a shower.
And while I was in the shower I was
sort of working on the song and sort
of coming up with it, which
again this is not my process
but words were coming, words
were coming, words were coming.
And I got in the cab
to go to the school
and I wrote fear never
wins that's what I hope.
See I said hope the work begins
as I was sitting in the cab.
And I was just holding the note
pad open like that and I walked
into a girls' school which was like,
that morning it was
like going to a wake.
It was unbearable what it was
like and it was totally silent.
But at the same time it was
this place that was all about,
even in light of what had just
happened lifting girls you
without saying to them you
can be what you want to be.
You can be the best
things that you have to be.
We will support you.
We will be behind you.
We will understand.
And I thought while I'm sitting
there with this notepad in my hand
that sings this song, I thought yes
this is exactly what I want to say.
I want to be in this place right
now with this, with this sentiment.
And our daughter was in doing
her interview and my wife
and I was just sitting out
there sort of in shock you know.
And she said to me,
what's on the pad?
And I said, I think it's a song that
I'm singing tonight for Kristin.
And she said, well do you
want to show it to me?
And I was about to start, just
in the hallway sort of singing it
and I couldn't actually,
I tried to open my mouth
and I started crying
and I said I can't yet.
I can't do it yet.
I don't even know if I'll be
able to do it tonight by I can.
And so then we got done
with the interview,
we dropped our daughter off
at school and we got back
into the house and Hillary was
about to give her concession speech
and we went into my room with the
piano and I said all right I'm going
to do this and this is the only time
I'm going to do it before tonight,
because I'm going to
have a nervous breakdown
if I keep singing this song.
So this is it.
And I played it sort of, I
mean I hadn't put my hands
on the piano at all
while writing it.
You had asked me about
this this morning.
I'm not usually a guy who can sort
of conceive all of this structure
without writing anything down
or playing it, but I just sort
of knew what the chords were.
So I played it, we just sort of
had our moment to send in catharsis
and then we went down
and watched the speech.
And I, you know, 6 hours
later I had to be on Broadway.
And at some point during that day I
think I finally did just record it
you know, on my little tape
recorder and I just put it online
which at least sort of said to
me all right, what I really,
I did that honestly so that Kristen
and her director could hear it
in case they were like oh God don't
sing that tonight, don't do that.
But fortunately they were both
like oh my God, you have to.
So I went and I sang it you know,
like I said Kristen's show
was all sort of sparkles
and you know soprano and
popular and all of that stuff.
And then she sang 50 Years
Long which is a you know kind
of moving moment, a nice moment and
then she introduced me and asked me
to come out on stage and I did.
And I said, I wrote
this this morning.
I don't know what to tell you.
This was the best I could
do and so I sang the song.
And I couldn't tell, you
know, there's a couple
of laugh lines early on in
the song as you guys know.
And so the audience
laughed thank God.
You know, they were sort
of relaxing with me.
And I got to the end and I
couldn't actually finish the song.
I sort of got the words out
somehow but it was just too much.
But we got to the end of the song
and the whole audience just stood
up in the middle of the show
and it was, it meant so much
to me, not like oh yay Jason.
But it was like, it was just a
moment where I was connecting
and saying something for all of
those people that they needed
to hear and I felt
very grateful for that.
And then there were the two guys
probably from West Virginia sitting
over here like this the whole time.
But you know, so that was
[inaudible] I got through 2 hours
without the f bomb, you've
got to give me a break.
>> This is the Library of Congress.
Shoshana Bean
>> There's no cursing here.
No cursing.
Jason Robert Brown
>> No cursing at all.
>> What is your relation,
both of you,
your relationship with an audience?
How does that effect you, influence
you, change your performance?
Shoshana Bean
>> I think for me, I think my
real, my strongest relationship
with audience has just
really begun as of late only
because I've stopped trying to
convince them or win them over
or impress them or get a
certain type of reaction.
Now when I come out my only
intention is to connect.
So regardless of the material,
if it's mine, if it's not,
my intention is just to
connect heart to heart and get
out of my head basically.
So, yeah I mean that's as
articulate as I can be.
>> But does what they give
you back effect what you do?
Shoshana Bean
>> I, it has the potential to yes.
And when they are excited and
enthusiastic and enjoying themselves
and making that plain it
certainly fuels the fire.
And when they are not it's
a challenge to keep grounded
and keep doing you know keep giving
your blood and your heart the way
that you would if they
were enthusiastic about it.
But I think my job is the same
regardless and that's kind of,
I don't know that you fall
into that trap like I do but.
Jason Robert Brown
>> I mean for me, I've always worked
blessedly under the assumption
since I started doing
concerts like this.
I work under the assumption that no
one's here to sort of hear me sing
and no one's really here
to hear me play piano,
they're here for the songs and
so I'm here to serve the songs.
And that's, I mean
that's a little bit coy
because obviously I know what
I can do and that I can sing
in a certain way and that I can
play the piano in a certain way
and I'll certainly throw
that out there you know.
But I like to think the songs
are doing the work for me
and I'm really here to channel them.
That said, I've had audiences
that are not prepared
to receive the songs.
It doesn't happen very often
obviously I mean you know,
I don't play to very large rooms
and honestly I don't
do that many concerts.
But I've had a couple of shows
in 20 years where I can just feel
like the audience was not really
buying what I was selling.
And honestly, you can
get crazy about that,
but maybe I just all those
years of having no one like me
in high school train
me to just you know.
You know, it's okay you
can have your experience
and if it's not the same one I
wanted you to have that's all right.
You paid your money,
you get what you want.
I'm sorry you're having
a miserable time.
It's going to be long
night but you know.
You know, I love to, there's
something about this kind of mix
that we have tonight where I can
tell there's easily half the crowd
that kind of can sing along
with all of it and know it.
And then another half of the crowd
that really doesn't entirely
know what they're in for.
And when there's that
balance it's a great thing
because you can feel the audience
sort of talk to each other you know,
that they just share this thing
that it's all right to like it
and it's all right to
be challenged by it
and it's all right to respond to it.
Were all going to be fine.
Whenever I have to
play for an audience
that really doesn't know
anything about my work,
that's a big uphill climb
because the material is so dense.
And a lot of it is so hard on you
know, first hearing that I have
to be very careful about
how I program that set.
And I tend to do a lot of
jiggering around while I'm
in the middle of playing.
I'll be like oh I was going to do
this song, I'm not going to do that.
Now let me just play.
So I can respond to the energy
that way and feel that way,
but so much of what I do with the
audience doesn't have to do with me
as a performer because I really,
most of my time I don't spend
thinking about when I sing it.
I spend most of my time thinking
about when the actor sings it,
when the character sings it.
So nights like this are sort
of fun, kicky little break.
But most of the work is about
eliciting and audience response
in a very specific way that's
built into the writing.
So if I've done that right,
hopefully when I perform
it, it's just sort of there.
>> What does it feel like having
sometimes say I Love Betsy is the
best opening number
since the Music Man?
Shoshana Bean
>> What?!
>> It did.
It's true.
[ Laughter ]
Jason Robert Brown
>> It was, you know, it was awesome.
The funny thing is, Honeymoon
in Vegas was never the
show I thought was going
to be Steve's cup of tea.
You know, I've known
Steve for a while
and like any young
writer Steve, he's Steve.
I can call him Steve.
But you know, like any young
writer of musical theater,
all I ever wanted to do was
to get Steve to like me.
I was like Steve please
like my work.
And so I think parade in the
last 5 years, those were the kind
of shows I thought he's really
going to get behind those.
He's going to be into those.
And he was kind of like yeah
those are nice and then you know.
Honeymoon in Vegas which is so like
down the middle 1961 musical comedy,
that's the one he's
like I love that show
and that opening number is the
greatest thing I ever heard.
He says, he told me that
he, he puts on the CD,
he drives out to Connecticut to
his country house every weekend
and he puts on I Love Betsy is the
first thing that he wants to listen
to in the car and he just puts in
on repeat and he listens to it over
and over again and he cries.
If anybody wants to know,
he cries all the time.
And, and I was like I Love Betsy?
Really? That's the one?
So I mean I'm grateful but,
that was, it was a surprise
that that was the one I mean I guess
he could've said Freaky Freaky,
that would've been even
weirder but you know.
Still, I Love Betsy, okay great,
I mean I worked really hard on it.
I'm glad it worked.
>> What do guys like
other than each other?
Are there?
Jason Robert Brown & Shoshana Bean
>> Nothing.
[ Laughter ]
Shoshana Bean
>> Very little.
>> Are there other songwriters
we should be looking for
and other performers who are up and
coming that we wouldn't know yet
but you guys see the spark in.
Shoshana Bean
>> Your, if you don't already know
Pasek and Paul you're about to.
[ Applause ]
That, those are the only other
composers that I get excited
about working with besides him,
like and I hope to God before one
of us goes that I get to
work with Steve, Steve.
But as far as up and
coming I'm not interested
in anybody else really
besides Pasek and Paul.
Jason Robert Brown
>> You know, yeah I
like Benj and Justin.
I think Joey Konas is really
talented, a very talented guy.
And you know, I'm married to
a very exceptional songwriter
so that helps.
Georgia Stitt, S - t - i
- t - t. There are a lot
of sensational performers.
I think in a lot of ways we've
reached a real golden age in terms
of the performers because
there's so much fluidity.
When I started, when we did songs
for A New World, it was really hard
to find that cast, especially
for the $20 we were paying them
but it was really hard you know.
Billy Porter and Andrea were both
people I knew you know, for many,
many years beforehand so they
sort of did it as a favor to me
and I built the show on them.
But it was a really hard show
to cast and it would not be hard
to cast it now, because the
vernacular has kind of grown
into what people are
more used to singing.
And I think that's true
of the musicians also,
I think with the stuff
I used to write,
nobody could play it you know.
Others are like oh I can do this
and now there's a lot of guys who
and girls who can get their
fingers around my stuff
and that's very gratifying.
I don't, I don't it's because
it's necessarily so much ahead
of my time, but I just think
that the work is kind
of filtered in its way.
Shoshana Bean
>> Well you change the
game for those of us coming
up like before you,
there weren't songs
like that you were
working on in college.
There weren't challenges
like that to be had.
You know, there's musical
theater singer's anthology
with like the basic soprano stuff,
the altos you know the usual stuff.
So you've changed that and
then as time has gone on,
social media has made that
more like accessible in a way
that wasn't necessarily for us.
We had to go to the
library and check out CDs.
Jason Robert Brown
>> We didn't even have
CDs when I was a kid.
[ Laughter ]
Shoshana Bean
>> Well yeah, well.
>> Did your daughter
get in the school?
Shoshana Bean
>> Did what?
Jason Robert Brown
>> Oh, we don't know
yet to be honest.
I sort of, I got over the hole.
She has to go to a girls school.
It was that morning, it was
really, really seductive.
And after that I was
like just, because I want
that doesn't mean that's
right for her.
And we went to a couple of other
non-girls schools and I was
like no actually she sort
of belongs here more.
No, I'm sure you're all
deeply, deeply interested.
>> They say leave them wanting
more and I want to save your voice
for Sunday after all
you've given us.
So thank you both for being here.
Jason Robert Brown
>> Thank you all very much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.